the Joe Rogan experience well if we ever
do eventually get to space travel if
human beings ever do figure out how to
like go to other planets and set up a
civilization on Mars or something that
that's probably what the real next level
future of humanity is gonna be but other
than artificial life if we can really
figure out how to set up a base
somewhere mm-hmm do you think you would
ever go if there was a base on Mars it
takes six months to go to Mars if there
was a threat on earth a threat yeah it
was like you know earth is about to be
[ __ ] up like an asteroid yeah I would
you know I would if if Mars was alright
I would try to go I would take my family
and go yep totally Wow
to save my family that makes sense to
save your family yeah whatever yeah what
if Mars was awesome what if they figured
it out if it was awesome
and I rather just die on earth yeah I'm
cool here oh yeah I'm good
yeah I just wonder once they actually do
start going from Earth to other planets
how many people are gonna be willing to
do that rich folks you think so I think
rich folks want to go into orbit I don't
think they want to go to Mars I don't
think there's a way to live there just
mate maybe if you can come back let's
say we're far in the future vacation
yeah take a little vacation to Mars it
takes money to get there everybody you
think if it takes six months to get
there hold on that's another one so long
I think I think a lot of people would do
that I think a lot of people would do it
I think you're right if they knew they'd
come back because then they'd be able to
brag about it
mm-hmm people would love to brag about
going to Mars it's like that time-travel
thing we're like take six earth months
to get there but over you it's like two
weeks
oh I don't think it works that way but
yeah I was wondering how doesn't it have
to be like at the speed of light yeah
yeah interesting you might be able to
save some time if you do that you could
lose some time though I know that's a
fact like if you go into space at a
particularly high rate of speed and then
you figured out how to come back like
your brother your twin brother would be
way older than you mmm yeah damn yeah
that makes sense
I want to see
Brian Cox showed in Brian Cox's to
astrophysicist he had a show he did in
LA and in the back they have this
gigantic screen and it's this real
high-resolution screen and it showed all
of the galaxies in the universe
and it showed all them that you know
just all jammed in together with like
appropriate space in between them and
you look at it and you just go what what
the [ __ ] is that we're in that thing
we're one dot in just trillions of dots
of all these other galaxies data through
the known universe I've never seen
anybody show it that way mm-hmm and one
of the things he talked about was that
the rate of time is not the same for
each person even on earth like depending
on where you go and what you do what
speed you travel at if you and I were
born on the exact same day and we both
got a watch and that watch was perfectly
calibrated and you put your watch on it
I put on my watch on then we met when
were 80 if our watches are still working
the time would be different mmm because
we've lived through different time and
it might be only increment like a tiny
increment like a second or a couple
seconds but enough so that in the the
whole unit a no sighs [ __ ]
so while I'm there watching this thing
the whole thing just blew me away I was
like this is a crazy way to look at the
universe this is it right here ah yeah
if anybody gets a chance to view that's
just one galaxy that they're showing
that was it's a one galaxy colliding
with another galaxy
it's [ __ ] spectacular whoa yeah do
you get in space documentaries about to
you got to I just don't believe
everything that everybody tells me so
what about [ __ ] like that so I would
have to get it from a reliable sports
source you would have to tell me like
the good okay space [ __ ] any Neil
deGrasse Tyson ones Lawrence Krauss has
got some good stuff he's got good
audiobooks to that Brian Cox guys as
good as it guys he's a genius
he used to be a musician okay he's
actually in like a pop band okay I think
in the 80s in the 80s you
like a popular pop man and he's a legit
astrophysicist he just talks about space
yeah he gives these very entertaining
with this guy Robin Ince and they have
this like stage show mm-hmm and you know
he comes out and talks about things and
explains things but explained when he
explained that time thing to me that if
we live the same life that our watches
would be different you know that's crazy
I love [ __ ] like that I'm writing his
name down Brian Cox CEO X not like the
dicks yeah I wouldn't put that name in
there course that could be a problem
yeah if you get a chance to see that
show man it's it's a it's a good thing
to see too because it's so different
than anything else you go to see like
for me I'm always at comedy clubs I'm
always saying you know either in the
audience or on stage and so to be there
at this place in the audience of this
weird kind of like show slash science
seminar and it's amazing now it's time
yeah that [ __ ] seems crazy as [ __ ] to
learn it laughs yeah I gotta I gotta get
you on some science documentary oh yeah
when you're smoking weed and watch its
science documentaries that'll help my
music listen the real thoughts come out
kids well you realize there's no getting
away if you if you you know that
paranoid feeling that you get sometimes
you get too high if you have that
paranoid feeling combined with a science
documentary on space mmm then you
realize like yeah we're we're all very
insignificant exactly and you seem extra
high because you're high watching space
yeah it's like the others do the stars
[Applause]